wir fahren raus richtung polnische
grenze zu den seelower höhen dem ort an
dem die schlacht um berlin entschieden
wurde als der krieg zu ende war mussten
die einfachen soldaten der roten armee
hier noch wochen oder sogar monate
verbringen ehe sie in ihre heimat
zurückkehren konnten
der archäologe thomas kersting statte
die hier im april 2015 mit seinem team
ausgrabungen um neue erkenntnisse über
das leben der rotarmisten zu gewinnen
was wir hier haben ist auch für uns neu
das hinterlassenschaften der roten armee
aus 1945 wie wir annehmen und vermuten
müssen und es handelt sich
offensichtlich um die reste von gruben
häusern von blockhäusern die halb
eingegraben sind und die hier an diesem
waldweg sich wirklich zu hunderten
befinden und wo tausende rotarmisten
untergebracht gewesen sein müssen
schauen wir doch mal runter wenn dieser
ein bisschen vorsichtig bestehen dass
zum welt ja das ist schon ein teil der
inneneinrichtung wir stehen ja jetzt
praktisch in dem rechteckigen haus sie
müssen sich vorstellen dass das also
blog wende hatte ein dach drüber und man
hat natürlich einen rufen gebraucht und
der rotarmist der schnitzt sich
natürlich einen ofen aus einer wasser
oder milchkanne noch wissen das nicht
genau das ist eine geläufige form so aus
den 30er jahren
da schneidet man ein loch hinein für
loch einen abzug oben und hat einen ofen
der wahrscheinlich die wurde dann ganz
gut heizen konnte man muss sich
vorstellen dass diese blockhäuser dass
es eine ganz gängige bauform natürlich
im slawischen bereich überhaupt seit
jahrhunderten durch den russland heute
noch angelegt und die soldaten haben
offensichtlich ich glaube abseits
eigentlich kriegerischer handlungen
diese ganz regelmäßige anlage hier
gebaut ich vermute nach der kapitulation
als noch nicht klar war wohin die vielen
vielen soldaten dann mal untergebracht
werden und so denke ich dass die hier
also in den vermutlich sommermonaten 45
gewesen sind und die haben hier gelebt
ihren alltag vollbracht wie bisher immer
so ist die archäologie die fast ja
normalerweise den den alltag des kleinen
mannes
und so ist es hier auch man sieht es an
fundmaterial also solche
einrichtungsgegenstände was solchen
geschosshülsen hat man sich zum beispiel
beleuchtung hergestellt da machte man
dort rein maschinenöl dann hatte man
also ein licht
wir haben alle möglichen anderen dinge
die zum teil militärischer funktionen
sind aber auch kuriose sachen die
erstmal überraschend sind wir haben also
eine ganze reihe von koppel schlössern
also militärischen gürtel schließen
auf den ersten blick sie sagen es
richtig das ist eine ursprüngliche
wehrmachts gürtel schließe gewesen man
sieht hier im innern den reichsadler und
das hakenkreuz aber außen mit uns gott
mit uns wie sich's gehört steht hier
alles drin in spiegelschrift außen hat
der russe aber es offensichtlich
geglättet und den sowjetstern
offensichtlich als siegeszeichen hier
aufgebracht und gerade eben haben wir
die kollegen dieses stück hier gebracht
ein sowjetstern ganz grob ausgeschnitten
aus blech das haben wir mittlerweile
dutzend und hundertfach das war den
einfachen soldaten offenbar so wichtig
sich selber dieses ihre eigenes sieges
symbol provisorisch herzustellen
das stand für die ganz groß im
vordergrund und hier auf dieser schnelle
handels ja gleichzeitig die über prägung
des faschismus die auslöschung also
besser kann man sich nicht wünschen die
klassische situation
und was hatten sie außerdem solche
schablonen hier einen ein aus einem ganz
starken blech ausgesägt und also solche
sterne darauf zu ritzen irgendwo aus zu
stanzen und ich finde das ist abseits
der ganzen historischen quellen die wir
natürlich haben natürlich weiß man was
im krieg gewesen ist was da nach dem
krieg gewesen ist aber wie der einzelne
kleine rotarmist so drauf war was der
wichtig fand in dieser zwischenzeit
zwischen krieg und frieden wenn man so
will
das fand ich schon verblüffend und sehr
eindrucksvoll dass das also bis zum
einzelnen man das so im vordergrund
stand dieses auslöschen dieses über
prägen dieses triumphieren wenn man so
will der der sowjetmacht das hat die
leute also offensichtlich bewegt